what made you take on something
emotional is this like because it's not
like a flippant podcast what made you
want to really take that on I like to
talk to people and I think it you know I
have a daughter with special needs and
she's got a very rare chromosomal
abnormality and and again I feel like in
special needs world and especially when
you know kids are younger it's like
we're gonna poor services into it but at
the in the back of your mind it's like
then they won't have it anymore you know
then they'll be normal you know and I
feel like being her mom has brought me
into the neuro diversity and disability
community where the people are awesome
and changing the culture and our brave
and yeah you know as my dad was my dad
was a sober alcoholic for 35 years and
he always used to say listen do I want
to be an alcoholic not really am I glad
for the going into this community and
all of the tools and people and amazing
journey yes so it's like a little silver
lining and people are super articulate
about it and I feel like it's a
conversation we all want to be having
and I'm just happy to be part of it
there are conversations that need to be
having and you just never know like all
those struggles we all go through well
and I I sort of articulated like it's
the it's the kind of goth cousin of
Oprah's aha moment it's the oh crap it's
like it's my hot seat it's like getting
the call it's like you need that Peart
is going on you know my passion
scalloping leukemia it's like you get
the call I didn't want that call you
know but then it's your turn and then
what happens I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my YouTube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this